I don't know any woman who would want to
be around you guys hilarious if I just
created a group chat with her and all
the living have been interested y'all
ladies why don't wanna read Oh today's
topic I got some very colorful messages
so Alba has been having some messages
I've been telling him about him being
careful about every time that he speaks
because sometime only speaks it really
looks like he's promoting himself I
don't mind it's fine it's cool this has
nothing to do with that this literally
has nothing to do with that here's what
happened okay
I received what maybe some of the
craziest messages I've ever seen in my
life now to be fair I don't know who
this person was so I woke up and I saw
don't you ever call me again and I said
who are you I didn't know who this
person was
I'm gonna say it's in her defense turns
out we did a live streaming during the
livestream at one point this girl sat
ABBA
I heard you dance dance for me and in my
head I was like if you don't get the cup
out of here telling me to dance like if
there's one thing that hurts me deep in
my soul a lot of dancers is when someone
finds out I do something they just
expect me to do it on the spot like I'm
some monkey for them oh you're comedian
tell me a joke right now you know I've
had this at parties I've had this has so
many events dance for me as if I'm you
you know I mean the word do you work at
at a bank open an account well it's not
you know the time for that exactly so so
I react and in her defense you know what
I was like okay maybe I'm in the wrong
but first I'm gonna just let Pete read
off the message preached read it with
her energy don't you ever come here cute
removing my comments Dan toxin coward
can't take the heat
no mo g emoji emoji God keeps telling me
to stay away from human trash
but I'm so hard-headed you were a dusty
bum Dan you feel a dusty bum now hold up
okay when I read this part of the
message I was half asleep and I was like
damn this new me in high school so I was
confused it was kind of dusty yeah cuz I
was just
so I was like how does she know me back
then and you were dummy - you say make
no sense at all
you think you're so smart lud emoji
emoji almonds you arrogant rightful hurt
fool
god damn this sounds like a good song
yeah you're prideful you arrogant and
not many people can stand to be around
you you're a judgmental to it you're
judgmental why or you are judgmental
unless she corrected herself as she goes
why oh you are Eve I'm like why I
respect it even when she's hating she
wants proper grammar correct respect you
think you're better than people the
energy you give up it's toxic we all see
it this is a long rough you're not even
10 percent in Jesus Christ how you
talked out the breach like either child
when one thing that I like is people
being mad about things that I'm not mad
about but okay I respect that
hey I need actually older than you thank
you very much you have no respect you're
disgusting
what did you do it's good until you bar
first on your Erica you're a dummy
you're disgusting you heard me I'm gonna
stop now cuz I know me and if I keep
going there a hole that's not you I hole
yeah it's hol whil in your soul and she
didn't correct it she's gonna tear a
hole in my soul okay I say nice thing
and you attack me I say dance for us cuz
I like your moves and you come you
that's and less is gonna bite your head
right off pieces shoulders down and I
wish I was there to watch I would bring
a big bag of popcorn and watch him rip
off your body distress now it's getting
creepy yeah that's what report
yes I watch many of the videos you were
where you danced and I was pleasantly
surprised yeah I'm suck from your BS
channels so get over it
stop being so emotional you'll never
find love you'll find someone who will
tolerate you and that is in itself is
pathetic they will not love you cuz
there is nothing to love you know she
reminds me of a girl that you used to me
yeah you know Shiraz Mia she reminds me
of remember that my experience being
ugly that guy from Sweden yeah the girl
that he was dated then she started
calling me and being like you should
take me back because you are unlovable I
remembered those words so clearly you
are unlovable if I was dating her that's
how she would talk yeah or she would try
yeah I just want to hear him come in and
be like and she's a terrible human being
she was actually a terrible human being
I've met I've met book and she is a
terrible human being
in fact it brings you joy to put down
others you have no wisdom you are fool
the wisdom you give to others is
supposed to bring them closer to you and
admire you and love you because they see
you have God's favor but you you have
the devil's wisdom Hey shout out to
Lucifer you reek of it the quote unquote
wisdom you give pushes people away cuz
you have to be right you feel everyone
around you is dumb you're a cocky is
just ill I don't know any woman who
would want to be around you guys
hilarious if I just created a group chat
with her and all the living who have
been interested and now your ladies why
do I want to lead
[Laughter]
if you ever dated me I put you in your
place so fast you drop to your knees and
worship me you would respect me and fear
me
you could never talk to me the way you
thought that he'd see you silly woman
who are you talking to girls like this I
bet you they like to get slapped up I
would ever do it cuz that's a crazy
relationship to be with but this is a
put that person that love to be very sad
you knew me in real life and dare to
slap me like you'd written those other
women I burn your house down okay Wow
that just finish this portion and then
I'll just respond how cuz I park my car
throw my keys in the woods read that
again cuz I'll park my car throw my keys
in the woods I thought I read that wrong
that's what's written if you wanna go
there
cuz I'll park my car throw my keys in
the woods okay and rip your pathetic
apart can I'll jump off the cliff just
for fun keep reading
meaning idiot when you think it's over
it's only just begun I'm sure what I
just said with my analogy went right
over that peanut head of yours okay hold
up this went over everybody's head oh
that must be it she's gonna throw keys
in the wood because she's not gonna back
out she's gonna go forward she's gonna
rip my two frets then after she's you
know epstein me right so because when I
die I'm like it's over
but then she jumps off the cliff right
then she goes to join me now because
he's not going to heaven because she
also has the devil's wisdom right and
then from there she'll be like you
thought it was over nah [ __ ] it's just
begun and then she drops a fire mixtape
right it really found like don't call me
with extra steps
so in short queue kiss here's the thing
you can't write 10 pages of insults and
then say in short no but you already
wasting my time that was nothing sort of
there's nothing worse than somebody who
comes to you with this long story that
noise ten minutes your time and then at
the end of it they're like to make a
long story short no it's a long story
long so she writes all of this and I
respond to her you're right I'm sorry
it's funny because you always told me
not to be sorry here's the thing I roast
people I have no problem for me it's
funny I laugh at people all the time but
with this person what it struck me is
that she just really wanted attention
that's what I suspect so to roast her
would have made her feel really good so
I'm like I'm gonna do this different
from once in my life mm-hmm and to be
fair to her when I called her I could
understand why she got a little bit like
mmm so you know what I'm like I'll give
it her all apologize and I'll leave it
at that
she writes afterwards thank you I
appreciate that
I didn't mean that for the things I said
and I'm sorry I'll go away now and for
the record you're smart I was just being
emotional you guessed it I mean not you
if you're watching yes you was right and
then a couple days later she came back
calling me a she came back yeah BAM I
know what that is what is it it's just
someone that's really unstable it's not
it happens it's mental issues is a real
thing yeah it's unstable it's back and
forth with this person and I'm a total
stranger and this person went off here's
what I did and the first time I ever did
this I reported her apparently her
account has been suspended or whatever
and the reason why reporters some of
them were like veiled threats you know I
mean I'll rip your head to shreds and
I'll jump off a cliff and I'll kill my
thing you can't be Brendan to people
yeah I think you did the right thing I
was just curious of what was behind her
foot so I remember at one point she
started messaging me like a whole bunch
of insults again and I'm like why do you
do this I think we were done but there's
nothing rational about this because it's
the truth
try the back in Footwear well no no she
started messaging me a whole bunch and I
was just curious yeah this I'm never
I've never been called before I was
really weird for me I was like okay but
I'm not remember like why would you
write this just kiss me I like
understanding why I do stuff yes and she
couldn't give me a rational explanation
this one I realize I can't understand
the irrational
look there's nothing rational to
understand right all right and that's
what I'm saying there is nothing
rational there to understand right and
actually
you have to be hmm in this line of work
that we're doing you are in contact with
a lot of people what we're in contact
with a lot of people and you have to be
able to decipher that right to know the
science I was able to know and be be in
contact with the science not only
because my parents they've been in the
health field and the mental health field
for my father but also being a bouncer
being a security guard I have to assess
the situation very quickly and who's in
front of me right if their action is
even rational or not right like how am I
gonna be able to respond like okay what
level of drunk of intoxication is going
on and my brother fate buddy you had too
much to drink and they're gonna act like
a five-year-old that's a normal drunk
they're just gonna go back on I'm really
drunk yeah I'm sorry any gonna hug you a
lie in there but they're not a threat
and they still can rationalize so you
speak to them but there are some people
there's nothing you can say there's
nothing you could say mmm nothing
rational about that but you have to be
able to decipher what it is
mind you that person that you're talking
about as being these messaging me really
yeah cuz I post means on my Instagram
okay so get out preach dimples on
Instagram whatever you're right Eric
them reach you're gonna find it but
anyways I post means that's my thing
right and one day she replied to it and
sometimes I reply to meme sometimes
don't sometime there's nothing to reply
just right emoji I was gonna be like hmm
or nothing there's nothing else it's not
a conversation so she writes an emoji I
see it I leave and she has this
conversation by herself by herself that
lasted a week and a half until you
approximately the dates where yeah that
happened
she had conversation hundreds
conversation by herself if I left it
alone because right there and then I
might mmm
and there's some people that you just
can't waste your time roasting sometimes
you got to learn one to walk away
sometimes there's some women out there
some people out there probably some men
too I imagine
who loved to fight who loved to argue
and even though I may have a better
argument in them sometimes the best
solution to what a situation like that
they said just walk away guys out there
I'm gonna give you an advice guys you
know you better watch out some girls
girls some girls they're only about that
thing that fighting thing and the guys
remember the second verse they're
talking to the girls through there's
some guys dude there's some people that
are really about that you know way they
engage in love is through conflict yes
that's all they know and you know you
said something a couple of weeks back
you said we were watching something that
was crazy I remember what it was and
what you said I can't argue with this I
can't argue with this because the person
is not playing by the same rules as
anybody else yeah and that's the same
thing yeah you can't argue with that
yeah there's nothing you could do it's
like playing basketball with someone but
they start off with a hundred points and
they'd have to dribble no they don't
have to George the score they just slap
two threes and then they get an extra
point it's like you can't win this game
yeah so sometimes they just take your
ball and walk away anything you want
about this that's pretty much it that's
pretty much it we have to watch out for
thing like that getting more and more
subscribers it's gonna happen I'm not
surprised by it yeah yeah I surprised
all like damn there's a lot of messages
they will imagine what popular women go
through what man yeah women must be even
scarier so I'm not gonna worry that the
Ruby's gonna blow up on me even though
there's potentially I'm not that worried
but for women who get these crazy
messages and they're scary yeah I
imagine I have to be a woman out there
when you do a lot meteor yeah yeah yeah
I see comment sections and I see how
crazy again yeah yeah but anyways that's
it for today's video we wanna know what
you guys think let us know your comments
below she was actually a terrible human
being
[Music]
hold on
welcome to another episode of ABBA and
preach and the floor if you don't like
the goddamn floor pay us to fix it okay
I think the floor adds character I'm a
big fan yeah yeah if you're hearing all
this noise that means our energy levels
are rising I mean it's real yeah if we
don't hear no noise because we're
standing still but if you gotta move
like this yeah when you hear Krakens
because we're we're practice and to be
fair it is much wrong all the floors are
like this all the floors all you talk
about is what you used to be like and
what you do the people know wisdom fool
no I'm sorry fool God loves a peacemaker
you are of your father the devil who
kind of gospel is this people actually
ask you for advice ABBA how do I make my
dreams come to you and make them a
reality
ABBA and get off your ass that's the
advice you think I would give that does
sound like advice I would give him Wow
groundbreaking advice you like the next
door doctor feel Abba how do I lose
weight I've been struggling with it
since I was a teenager Abba get on a
treadmill
Brad fo you thought literally these
[ __ ]
no but I'm looking for sometimes then
they begin to a poopoo and the other one
is easy to get hot jack look at this one
huh the other man is poo-pooing in his
mouth and he begins to leak it's like
ice cream
Bishop sterilizer this is a parental
guidance moment yes yes that child that
child can be removed your heart is black
and you know it my heart is made of fire
but if your heart is made of fire
sometimes at some point it's gonna run
out and it's gonna
bleh boo boo you're so sensitive your
arts made of snowflakes calm down and
you know it
Meyers made a fire it burns when I come
across your soulless human you fell out
super violent she keeps writing you were
wrong now yeah I guess as this
conversation went on her priority
shifted your heart is black and you know
it my heart is made of fire but if your
heart is made of fire some of that at
some point it's gonna run out and it's
gonna be black boom ooh you're so
sensitive your arts made of snowflakes
calm down and you know it Meyers made a
fire it burns when I come across your
soulless human you fell out super
violent
she keeps writing you were wrong now
yeah I guess as this conversation went
on her priorities shifted
[Laughter]